serious health news for the Today Show's  Al Roker hospitalized again get ready to  leave the hospital time to blow this  taco stand  woohoo  a source close to Al tells E.T just one  day after being released from treatment  for blood clots in his leg and lungs the  Beloved weatherman was rushed back by  ambulance the day after Thanksgiving  Al's wife GMA reporter Deborah Roberts  reportedly became so frantic to follow  him to the ER that when her car wouldn't  unlock she tried breaking a window it's  hard to slow down now but he's he's on  the mend and he's on the way Al's been  off the Today Show for four weeks and  missed co-hosting the Thanksgiving Day  Parade last week for the first time in  27 years Al's recovering and he's  recovering very well from a recent  medical issue we just want to say we  love you Al tonight the 68 year old is  out of another live TV holiday tradition  the Rockefeller Christmas tree lighting  airing on NBC